doesn't really get much better than that
Gabrielle Union on why Jessica Alba is
the perfect partner in crime for their
new bad boys spin-off LA's finest it's a
spinoff my character said from bad boys
to she's now in LA she's partnered with
Jessica Alba's character they're both
sort of rogue detectives we're still
giving you that big Jerry Bruckheimer
action comedy but with two kick-ass
women but I love about Jessica is that
she's she's women can relate to her
she's she's a mother of three but while
also at the same time creating a
billion-dollar company that's all about
you know the health and and wellness of
your of your families and and she's sexy
as hell and she's a kick-ass action hero
by day the actress stunned in a black
sequin spring 2019 Ralph Lauren
collection gown while at the New York
premiere of her new film the public
which hits theaters April 5th the
unidentified homeless man was found dead
just outside the doors of the public
library I heard two more people froze to
death
and against his cold I don't know why
they don't just let us stay here my
character is trying to advance in her
career and hurt it's her job to report
the truth but she perhaps you know leans
into alternative facts to kind of
increase the clickbait and over the
course of the film she has to kind of
make a decision you know what's more
important getting the truth out or
career advancement these things very
rarely and wealth
the issue surrounding homelessness are
very vast you know but what we tackle in
this film addiction our treatment of our
veterans you know what is that what is
the duty of you know of our of our
public spaces when you think of
libraries as sort of the last the last
hope for a lot of people the last place
we can get free information they have
air conditioning in the summer heat in
the winter clean bathrooms they have you
know librarians who now a lot of times
are trained as social workers what is
our duty or am I am I my brother's
keeper all things that we have to we
should really question I think we are
[Music]